this man got him did a lot peace be with
you welcome back to the D show
I'm your host and in the detials studio
for those gamers out there who love
playing Grand Theft Auto my next guest
was on the soundtrack that in the first
week sold 6 million 6 million records
and he was with the likes of Russell
Simmons was hooked up with the Def Jam
was around many famous celebrities
rappers work with Nike and the brother
today is helping in his community doing
so many good things helping people stay
away from trouble so we're going to go
ahead and get into dig a little bit into
his life and his experiences so we can
all benefit with my next guest gatir
Latif here Nadeem show we'll be right
back
this is the this is the venue this is
the days of the engine you know this is
the things faster on the G show special
guests in the D show studio how you
doing my brother LA you pay for it play
for the Chicago Bears no you play
football now play basketball classic of
all yeah we were you weren't in the NFL
no some people might think Manish
brothers are running back i heard that
not a runner yeah it doesn't hurt all
the time
um did it luck so 6 million records or 6
million sold in the first week yeah
russell simmons people know Russell
Simmons mm-hmm was he with bad boy nah
not bad Jeff Jam Jam Master Jay yeah all
of these rappers people idolizing them
and you were stuck in that rut for a
little bit but you got out yeah so tell
us a little bit about this tell us a
little about your bio and you know this
6 million so grand theft auto well Kadir
Latif I went to Howard University to
play basketball in a scholarship and I
perform poetry and we did a vent for
Russell Simmons and I perform last and I
at the end Russell Simmons sent his
contact and they came to me and said we
want to want to work with you and just
you know they said no they gave me many
you know compliments and a couple weeks
later they invited me to perform at Jam
Master Jay Z memorial at a private event
in Jamaica Queens and I've started
meeting so many people like getting
business cards and just people started
reaching out you know
[Music]
and I didn't yet started open up to you
huh
it started opening up the old I started
opening up you know start doing a lot
start traveling a lot and I got
management and I started working you
know it even though you know cinder
Hollow and then you try to keep it
allowed when you when you let little
things get in you know it kind of soils
it so I was doing work for Nike for
Reebok I'm working with DJ Green Lantern
I was M&Ms DJ at the time but not does
DJing for nas and jay-z we did a lot of
different things we did a whole mixtape
project feature the white clef on their
stops peels on there you know a lot of
the MCS and it kind of you know you
started you started start chasing it
like once you started getting around it
you really want to start like you want
to be big and you want the money so you
know you start compromising and then you
start compromising your beliefs and you
start compromising who you are mm-hmm
and next thing you know you know my last
biggest accomplishment it was an O eight
or a seven
I submitted a song to grant on the grand
theft auto 4 the last one that came out
and it was on a video game but they had
a special soundtrack and it was so many
artists from the veal game like you know
hundreds that they only could pick like
you know seventeen artists so it's gonna
be like mainly sign artists but they
picked four rappers and it was nas which
was signed Mobb Deep Busta Rhymes and
they picked me and they picked my song
to go on the soundtrack and they sold it
with a veil game and it sold you know
six million in the first week it broke
records on how many albums so people
started talking about the song and the
song started being on the internet and
people you know on websites and just it
really started blowing up but at the
same time I was getting really you know
for some reason I could never just be
comfortable in it I could never my wife
you know my kids
I'm looking at them they're always
reminders you know but you put yourself
in these situations and these situations
in the club you know people smoking
drinking wiling and after a while you
almost get yourself caught up so you
know from the love man I had the law
gave me the insight and the courage to
you know to just put everything down to
just you know focus and really make a
comeback so you had the the opportunity
to design and go deeper but what you
started to reflect you saw is this grand
theft auto is not sending a positive
message the song wasn't it wasn't a
positive song it wasn't a horrible song
but it wasn't you knows that that great
you know you wavered in that if I
pursued it then they would want more
music like that that's what that that's
what they that'll be my first
introduction to the world will be you
know a song about guns or whatever yeah
and I didn't want that for being tested
in this life and everyone has a
sacrifice and if we sacrifice in this
life for the crater we get the word in
the next life so insha'Allah Allah
accepts it that you sacrificed you
didn't you didn't you didn't sell out
because people sell out yeah you know so
halal may Allah help us did Creator
helped us to stay what's on the way
that's pleasing to him so continue going
on you know you kind of you know you
grew up in Buffalo your Buffalo New York
and we want to reach out to the people
out there who are having a hard time
well the cupboards are filled with xanax
antidepressants or maybe not even that
just drugs and alcohol people have
turned to to to the bad life thinking
it's the good life and you had a taste
of that and you were just sharing with
me a story right you were staring me a
story about you know you're involved in
a community that someone who was a
former gang bang gang member and mafia
guy whatever tell us about the story
it's a guy who was he was
on to being the streets at hamdullah I
took a shot we worked with him and he
took a shot I became Muslim and
sometimes your old life
it just doesn't like disappear you know
you do bad things you got to pay the
consequences so he's been doing real
good
you know and recently before I came out
here you know he called me emergency
emergency you texted me what what was he
like former he was just he's not now he
was uh like a big guy I mean he was he
was just see what he was a street boy
like a real life like a drug lord or
something like that
one said juggler but he was he was like
a big to the bad guy in the street yeah
bad guy in the streets you know um and
I'm the lie became Muslim most of my
friends who I played like a lot of my
friends I played basketball with who I
hung out with when I was in the streets
hanging out they become Muslims so I'm
the lot like you know there's no law
that they can relate they can relate to
what I'm saying and they they see me
when I was down and a you know seeing
now that I'm you know more conscious and
getting involved in the community and
pulling these guys away from these
situations and he called me come to LA
but he want what he wanted to do was
Street retaliation stuff and I we went
to the mass yeah we kicked it so you
were saying the guy shoot at him well
that guy he saw that he's seen it he
didn't know the guy though Yeah right
against who some some gang stuff going
on from one side of town the other side
of town he was just going to the store
yeah and he just came back in town
actually you know he went to the my shed
in Virginia and he came back and
somebody shot at home so he calls you
now so he calls me and says yo somebody
shot at me that's what I want to do I
want I want to get whoever I think it is
and I said so he's doing his instinct
that's one thing for him to say you know
run up run up in a mother house whoever
and get him whoever we who he thinks he
don't even know who it is that's the
street man Terrell a street mentality
that's before a slando before Islam
Salaam calms you down put your head
right pat you don't think like that
number yeah so what happens next
so I go I pick him what the person we
thought it was I knew the person we
thought it was so I went and I
investigated in
and cause it's the guy was from my
former amount of my old neighborhood so
I went investigated and it wasn't that
guy so I went to having explained that
you know you have to have witnesses
first of all an Islam just can't do
nothing do do something without having
witnesses and knowing that you know
appropriate you know way to do it and we
went to the mashing we talked to be
targeted you know talked about Prophet
Mohammed Islam and he was like you right
there and I'm the law he didn't do
anything and he just prayed he you know
showed his growth cuz so if this
situation is diffuse effuse even we
can't even take the law into our own
hands he launched wrong yeah so you
defuse a situation and now is his
brother coming around that his character
is changing becoming a better human
being all around yes yeah beautiful
you've seen I mean I'm sure you've seen
some of the the most you know corrupt
people yeah have you seen them and then
how after they've you know submit to the
will of God some into the will of crater
that's what a Muslim is right but some
people like right now because we have a
lot of not yet Muslims out there people
you know everyone I say always always
that everyone has potential to submit to
the Creator but someone says look
because nowadays you have all this false
propaganda with violence being a tribute
to Islam they say yep that feeds into it
but I got to swords around his neck he's
ready to chop us up what do you guys say
about this this right here is this a
shield of the Ottoman Ottoman Turks yeah
you know and it's also a symbolism as I
represent I protect the purity and in in
the art of poetry yeah you know I
protect it you know but it's not like no
this is you know this is if you listen
my lyric you just know Lyle he's not the
type of guy yeah but but you know a
protector of the art to keeping it pure
and keeping it you know he's a build-off
yeah so it's not promoting that cut
somebody up front
nobody knows math it's not gold no it's
not gold either with brass but yeah
people thinking all sorts of thing we
want to just you know ya know skeptic
out there just answer clear his doubts
we're gonna we're going to continue on
with this interesting segment here on
the Deen show with my brother and your
brother
Kadir Latif here on the Deen show don't
go anywhere
[Music]
is your boss driving me crazy
are you just living from paycheck to
paycheck party to party and everything
is just getting tiring it's getting
played out and you're asking yourself
what's this all about what's the purpose
many people don't reflect like I mean
why am I here you're born to die and
then what do you gotten between me it's
a big drama some days are good some days
are bad some days you're sick some days
you sad we not you might not make it to
85 years old we might not make it till
tomorrow and this is something that we
need to think about the lights will go
on after the party and the party will
end and you will be alone and you will
have to be accountable for everything
you've done
life is not all about just chasing that
man or woman or that good time it's not
all about the baseball game in the
basketball game and chasing a position
and getting a lot of wealth and money
there's more to dis life and it's up to
you to be sincere enough within yourself
and to want to know more what's the
purpose what's it all about life
[Music]
who
[Music]
who
[Music]
show us the way to other squids this is
back here on the Dean show and we're
talking to brother Latif tell us now if
you know further for the person who like
they love turning into the Dean show
because you know we talk about real
issues we try to connect with the people
who are living in a culture that is cool
to be bad the inoculum right and it's
cool to be out there in the nightclubs
you know taking advantage of the women
women flaunting it for the wet men and
getting taken advantage of so you're
also out there now someone who's trying
to help invite people to goodness that
good organic way of living a good
wholesome light that's pleasing to the
Creator because we know that you know at
the end we're going to die and all this
stuff is just a false Mirage that people
are chasing so what do you when someone
is out there you know they they're like
you know what I don't want to talk about
religion you know all religions are
man-made how can someone be sure that
look Islam is some is a way of life
that's from the crater it's not just
like every other man-made religion right
if you believe in not believing in God
you still believe in something and this
is the concept people don't understand
if I say I believe in God you say okay I
don't believe in God you still believe
so you have the understanding of belief
but though some people look at you know
science and say well you know science
everything was created through science
but even Allah God created science if
you look at the Quran Allah talks about
the clouds and meteorologists you know
20 years ago just start you know
discovering that when the clouds get a
certain size 2530 feet they shoot out
hell hell comes forms they layer and
then health drops in the Quran it talks
about a loss I'll put mountains in the
sky and they hit and the hell comes and
hits who we please it so we will so
meteorology just a study that instead
chronic see how the crime know that
talks about the moon how the law user
compares it to a palm a palm leaf
because the palm leaf was wet and it
dries out and he said a dry you know
dried palm leaf and he said this is the
moon but the scientists say the moon
just have water in it and they dry and
they dried out how is this discovered
how the two sees me together did clean
and the pure and the salt and they never
transgress with Jacque Cousteau found
this out if if you have 1400 years ago
Proc muhammad peace upon him wasn't a
scientist you know and also look at the
nature look at the nature of Islam the
Brotherhood in Islam it's something
that's it's a special bond where I know
guys who went to jail one guy went to
jail another guy was in the street took
his Shahada friend of mine he came to
the Masjid we praying together we were
praying for like the last couple months
the guy gets out of jail and sees this
God now this guy took like some dope
like robbed him for some for some drugs
and their time of in the streets and
they're doing you they seen each other
they hugged and cried and loved each
other because they both so they hated
each other
back in the days of ignorance yeah they
both became once we submitted to the
will of the crater Muslims and now they
got this love not I mean now they love
each other yeah I know
and this is all coming from Islam how
Islam you can't like have a CUFI on and
say okay I'm gonna be most of you most
of my newly Muslim I'm gonna shoot at
you we're gonna be whatever you know you
see this sometimes in my community you
see people who say mostly these guys
kill each other they said a Christian
that's that's their understanding but
there's nothing to stop them to say okay
I'm gonna kill you you'll kill me it's
just like I think the example of Jesus
alayhi Salaam has been kind of like
smothered out a little bit the true
example so a law says I've sent this
Quran you know not as a new religion but
as a preservation and a confirmation of
what I once sent when you look in the
Quran you find everything about Jesus
you find it you find muscle doing
everything Jesus do we agree we greet
peace be upon you may God's peace um
doesn't be upon you this is how Jesus
greeted if you see upon him we pray we
prostrate to the flow
or this is how Jesus Abraham Moses
postulated to the floor they wash their
hands feet in their face
this is what Jesus Moses and Abraham did
we don't eat pork then let's talk a
moment about pork ham bacon pepperoni
these are some of the things that the
scripture tells us we should not eat you
know we don't we don't drink alcohol the
first miracle and of Jesus was turning
water into wine this is according to the
into the Bible but the first miracle in
Islam was Jesus speaking from the cradle
and if you look at the story of the wine
turning water into wine you look at a
contradiction because the master of the
ceremony according to the Bible said why
have you brought us a good wine after we
have been well drink the scholars say
that was about he made about 450 gallons
of wine that's what Jesus made the the
emcee at a ceremony said why have you
brought us this good wine after we have
them well drink they're sending the
Bible to be drunk
so after you've been well Drake meaning
you drink the good wine then you drink
the bad wine that was the tradition and
after that tradition I mean a contrary
tradition they drink the goat wine the
bad wine then Jesus made 450 more
gallons for a group of 300 to 350 amount
of people then they will be getting
drunk but you find these consistencies
of alcohol you find mentions of incest
that the prophets did incest you find
mentions of drunkenness you find a drug
mentioned in the Bible it's called
Mandrake a Mandrake also known as The
Devil's whoop it was used medically for
anesthesia but it was on the black
market it was used as a date-rape drug
okay like an ecstasy so you find two
stories in the Bible of mentioned in the
songs of Solomon that someone has taken
a Mandrake
according to love I love my love the
Mandrake's are fresh meaning I love you
we're going to take this Mandrake it has
nothing to a medical but you find the
Roman or European culture twinkle all
through the Bible with a lot of incest
with drunkenness but in Islam Allah
clears all the profits of those things
so Islam is this bringing you back
you know to the pure that man has
corrupted and in the Bible another many
many of our brothers in humanity don't
know that that we believe that there is
some of the word of the creator in the
Bible but it's being contaminated being
corrupted that's why you see some of
those false stories that are attributed
to the best examples of mankind you'll
see the prophets were the best
they can't be you know doing horrific
crimes and expect you know us to be you
know saints and angels right have the
best behavior if they're doing they have
to have the most pristine character and
that's what Islam Allah clears them of
all these files not false notions like
you know like you you mentioned that
incest was that prophet lute with his if
you just just quickly on that if the
Christians believe you believe a sin is
a sin a sin is a sin we're going to say
as soon as the sin that's the Christians
believed the Bible teaches sentence a
sin so if as soon as the sin why did God
save lot and his daughters right now
when he sent this brimstone and it's
fire and brimstone down it came down and
it came down so quick it's like somebody
shot a gun in this room in you were hit
the floor that's how a hit boom don't
look back just one but they run to the
mountains right now later on that story
his daughters get him drunk at what
point in time did they just did they say
boom the fire and brimstone come down
hold on let's wait let's get this wine a
hold on like no they didn't get wine
when would they get wine you came to
look back it was that serious so the
women got the wine went to the mountains
got him drunk which was the sin incest
which was the sin fornication which was
a sin so you're looking at once in that
of the homosexuality if as soon as the
sin they did their one sin that's their
one sin they did three sins why will God
protect them and abolish them and do it
and keep them you know it's a
contradiction a crime is a crime yes a
crime is a crime but there are different
levels of penalty to every crime they
say that if you look at someone in
Christianity that is just like doing it
but a law says if you look at her if you
go get her number but you remember me
and
you know I can't do this a lot with
words you for self-restraint and you not
rewarded for self-restraint yeah now
yeah before we get off this topic I mean
but did you clear because you obviously
uh you study the Bible a little bit you
did most people who have accepted Islam
you know they look and they look at the
different religions they you know and
then they come to Islam after they've
investigated everything else most people
become atheists because they see that
all these contradictions in the man-made
religions so they put it all in the same
bunch as that all of this is man-made
but there's no way if you really
scrutinize Islam you look at it
sincerely you'll see that it cannot come
from the creation it comes from the
Creator now this idea you know we look
we never want to hurt anybody's feelings
we sincerely want you know to educate
the people and have them really look and
think you know behind behind just
blindly following their culture their
ancestors or their uncles fathers no
closest of kin and think for themselves
you'll never find anywhere in the Bible
where Jesus ever said that he was God to
worship Him do you ever find out never
you don't you never find out he says I
am God you find someone else saying it
but you never find him taking soul a
sonship either you never find him saying
every time you say I'm son he will say
my god you're God mm-hmm I'm a child and
you're a child you know he always made
reference our father he always made
reference to her not just him never
never did he take sole ownership of just
I'm just a son no he said we are sons
yeah we all children yeah so I mean
that's a son of God with someone who was
pious righteous close to good if you
really look at the Africa
african-americans look back at their
history if you can go a year wash the
route there was the roots good the King
Tay he was Muslim he was one submitted
to the will of God isn't it was the
majority of Africa they were Muslim any
any african-american who goes back to
deep to his rural register richest man
that ever graced the crusted his earth
according to today's discovery was
Mansur Khan Khan Moussa who made Hajj
and who went to Egypt engage some ones
go to way they changed the economy for
20 years this is Mansur Khan kamusta the
king of Mali you know 13th century
you're talking about
look at Africans and look at the
Timbuktu when the first universities
where we're we're built around three
masjids so this is something that shows
you that before we came here we weren't
but the Bible has certain passages that
say if you're a slave and you're a
Christian slave work even harder for
your master
so who that benefit know they had to
take this mile from us
and had to force us to to accept the
doctrine that enslaved us
I heard we got to go to break but I
heard you know this is historically true
where you know the African Americans
were given the the Bible and then they
gave the African Americans the Bible and
it took their land took the letter get
in the Bible and it made them submissive
but the same person giving you heaven
will never give you hell the same person
give you hell will never give you heaven
so if I hate you and I'm gonna rape your
mother and rape your baby to rape your
husband raping a man man raping a man
and they're gonna do all that they won't
say hey I love your buddy here find
Jesus okay no that's that's not how it
works
yeah as Muslims we love Jesus no Muslim
is a Muslim like to believe in Jesus but
like many scholars who accepted Islam
know where Jesus ever claim God a little
son of God but he worshiped God he was a
Muslim one who submits to the will of
God would be right back with more here
on the Deen show this is my family if I
ain't got
but he's always been stubborn he started
having his problems
he's gonna clearly fight one night
policeman told me change ready son
father come on get him from the station
he's like one fight here have a fight
there his physical beam was great
burrows ego but he left him empty I'm
running here running there and the
outside people looking in today this is
the man
everybody knew Eddie at any given moment
you could have 78 women that are running
around the club looking why he did
things that he he pushed himself to the
ethical extremes that he could I have to
get out of this totally right near the
end there was just a boy it was a
constant struggle there was in her soul
that broken into him
there was that emptiness in his eyes it
was a big round penis that I think I've
ever really seen in his eyes
that I see heaven
it was dr. Jekyll miss ride and he was
struggling with it but the effort was
there there's a conscious effort to make
this switch
who bans and started talking to his back
look at him it's Carnegie our good guy
this was the reality it was bad couches
Bobby only cried ladies consequence one
is social and his time is spread to the
knowledge well people didn't know who I
was but why are you doing this hold on
thicknesses you're looking a dream
that's ten people were just stubbornly
resistant and start looking at you like
you're from outer space
I have to be out there trying to
convince people to be on the show the
first episode of that show aired I think
that's when you saw the full pollination
coming to Soho this guy's change what's
going on here is he's a machine
I know but to see someone changed to see
their character changes you see positive
changes in their life it's a sign of God
back here on the Dean show and we're
talking to brother Latif former artists
with the soundtrack that sold six
million records on grand theft auto and
you worked with the likes of Russell
Simmons and you investigated the
different religions out there and you
came with full conviction out to know
that I mean because everyone even if
you're born one in a Muslim family you
have to make a conscious decision
because you have many people are going
with the rituals they haven't totally
submitted but you you've investigated
and you've seen you know this is indeed
from the Creator so how do you when you
when you're talking to the to the rough
and tough and you know the brothers and
you know and humanity and people who are
out there on the streets and they're
just wasting their life gangbang in
selling dope selling drugs emulating
$0.50 and J
z what do you tell them you know to try
to get them away from destroying their
lives I mean you have to understand the
people you have to understand the
culture you have to understand the
mindset you have to understand the pain
the pain is very important prophet Milan
said Salaam when you look at promises to
live and you look at when he came to
Islam before before he came to Islam
Christians were hopes it 80s were
thought it wasn't but he stayed that
drew he kept that dress because he
didn't want to be unfamiliar he added a
kulfi under the turban and he added the
kulfi so he could and on the beard so
they can different differentiate so he
wanted to look familiar
meaning you have to people have to know
that you can you understand my plight if
he came over there with suit and tie
then it would look at him and say first
of all you don't you know you don't
dress like me I mean you don't come from
where I come from so visuals is that I
feel it's a big thing so with Islam I
try to even on Muslim I try to keep the
dress of the people in my community
meaning I want real silk I want with
gold
I want wear tight stuff but I wear
things that's modest like the Quran
prescribes us so we can first have a
visual understanding that I come from
where you come from
second I know the pain in the hurt and
the once and the pleasures and desires
that this dunya gives because I chased
it also but there's something greater
there's something way greater than this
moment of getting drunk or a moment of
smoking weed or having a little money in
than spending and always chasing it
there's something much greater when you
leave here and I gotta ask them do you
believe that do you believe that when
you die what's going to happen it's just
going to be over just use a little fall
asleep that's not know you got to pay to
play there's a price to everything you
do and I have to remind them that
there's a price and I say look if you
Christian look at Jesus if you look at
Jesus life some people say what would
Jesus do
but then but it's not they don't really
do what Jesus did so you have to say
what would Jesus if you really believe
what Jesus do then look at the way
Muslims to conduct their lives every day
pray without ceasing it says in the
Quran prayer without ceasing without
stopping that's in the Bible they said
it means Paula it's in the Bible it says
pray without ceasing so you look at I
actually vote how do you pray without
ceasing just walking just prayed no how
do you pray without ceasing what I'll
stop you don't say you don't stand the
old you start the prayer of mind and
unfocused in and oh that's nice nice
it's not even you know realistic but if
you look in the Bible Peter looked at
the Sun and told Jesus it's time to pray
it's a verse in the Bible that says that
I forget the but he said look at the Sun
it's time to pray so you look at it's
Lyman and we look at the Sun and we know
by starting positions of the Sun going
down tonight sundown what time it is
what time it's time to pray so you find
these these things that confirm each
other and it pushes them but when people
come to Islam from you know Christianity
from the streets they find a peace that
they couldn't find in that life even
though they had money yet people come in
something has so much money and they may
not haven't sent my money but they have
a lot more peace and this is what Islam
gives it's a peaceful submission and
this is what people really want because
they're fitrah the natural inclination
is to do good and we have to start
aiming at that not judging them not
coming down on them but waking that
aspect of them up to remind them that's
a good good reminder judging is one
thing that's left for the crater but
giving the sweet advice that advice that
if somebody was give you advice to
invest in a stock that's going to hit
high you know one hundred percent
guarantee you'd be investing right but
this Dean when you invest is way of life
in the Creator you got nothing but good
that's going to come from it and this
life and definitely in the paradise and
the next so we're almost out of time but
you're you you do this this what's
called a spoken word like PO
treeger with without all the guitars and
all the other stuff right you do it just
not I made a CD with pure natural sounds
here natural sounds mushroom but no now
I do have a I do have you know according
to a hat like a hip-hop CD but I try to
make something that's how loud I feel
you know so you got you talked about the
prayer and this yeah right because you
got a lot of those people who again this
is the advice because we love we love
you know we if you don't love for your
brother you know love for you for your
brother what you love for yourself
you're not truly believing so we love
for our brothers to to connect with the
crater to the ones who haven't accepted
this beautiful way of life the way of
life that Jesus lived Abraham lived
because Abraham Abraham was not a Jew or
Christian he was one who submitted to a
little god that's a Muslim right Jesus
was a Muslim all the prophets were
Muslim they submitted to cannot Jesus or
two human beings they submit it to God
to the maker so after that step there's
a time that you have to commit you know
you don't just fit Islam in right where
you want it you got to fit everything
else into something so many people are
not praying but you know not going to
Jamaa so we want to give that advice and
you give it through the spoken word
isn't it so can you go ahead and share
some of that with us that addresses some
of these things you know the abandonment
of prayer and jahmai and some of the
other vices but we motivate you know
some people to do these wonderful
actions okay I said um I never ask a man
for help I ask Allah and think about
death so I stay enough Sarat and when no
one's looking you sneak and give zakat
allahu la allah has Shaitaan leaving out
my spot you rush to work but you late
force a lot a Muslim never brags but its
actions say a lot you don't care soccer
for law you don't share stock for law
you fear the cops but you have no talk
of Allah
you want a piece at a profit but not
peace for the profit when a piece of the
problem you want a piece of the profit
but not peace for the prophecy that
money is your lords and you worship an
object you don't invest into your Deen
no spiritual deposit is the message and
the messenger protected like sahabas got
to clean out my closet like Mohammed did
the car bus their way from the Falana
when death is upon you so we run the
colleges but don't run to mallanna's
know
to tap or put on you learn words to a
song hit my ties buy a thong you ain't
watching for Shaitaan you watch the
weight you put on fantasize buy calories
while Palestine count casualties
fantasize buy calories while Syria count
casualties and shakes at grave recite
yaseen over anatomies where your reality
is Applebee's Johnny was hanging slave
from apple trees no apple seeds just
lowercase lies and capital catastrophes
bold print blasphemy italic strip
idolatry and you can find me where the
scholars be saying that a man Orihime
and Malik before got my head on the
ground and my knees on the floor and the
devil on my ear Eddie telling me to
trade it for the world
but I won't trade it for the girls I
won't trade it for the pearls I won't
trade it for the cars
I won't trade it for the Gees I got love
for my ox and I pull him out the street
because of you laying with the dogs
then you're sleeping with the fleas and
the pen is mightier so I'm writing el
aziz allah aziz al Jabar mutakabbir
allah aziz al Jabar al mutakabbir no
blunts in the air no punks in my square
no tight jean here they get pushed to
the where just to pump in this little
slump from the fair i got your hide on
my lips asking allah to bring me closer
to you hold me like a baby
it's llamas the truth and that's no ants
if buts or maybes hey I'm the love thank
you for being with us at the beach I
hope that woke up some people from the
deep sleep that they're in law no test
some of the hearts by the crater to
heaven and the earth rewards you thank
you thank you brother thank you
subhanAllah hamdulillah
you know praising the crater you know
doing the wonderful things that he's
told us to do I hope you know listening
to some of that poetry woke some of the
hearts up that are in a deep sleep like
the brother said hypnotized by a thong
or some jay-z song I mean that stuff's
really not going to help to develop you
to be the best human being that you can
be and that's you know what the Creator
wants from us that's why he sent
messengers throughout time and none of
them called human beings to worship
human beings
you know Jesus never call people to
worship himself you know Abraham Moses
and the other messengers that the
Creator sent Mohammed being the last
they all came with the straightforward
simple message worship the Creator not
his Christian and do good prepare for
death because after death you're going
to be judged as a day of judgment people
want justice and you might have went
through all sorts of trial in this life
because this life is a test and many
people might have not gotten brought to
justice and everyone wants justice so
what would it be if the person who
believed in God and gave the most out of
their wealth and at the end that person
suffered so much I mean and they just
died it doesn't make sense and the next
like they'll be rewarded or the
criminals that just did all sorts of
scandalous things ripped off everybody
and their mother and killed everybody
and and pillaged and raped at the end it
doesn't make sense that that person just
dies and that's it it's finished the
Hitler's of the world for example that's
why the day of judgment just makes sense
it makes sense and that is what all the
messengers of God brought and taught
they gave the good news that if you do
good suppress your desires work for the
hereafter being in this life as a
traveler but be the best that you can be
you know whatever career you chose be
the best but be a best and don't forget
the test that we're living and then
prepare you know for that day of
judgment and they also gave the warning
about the Hellfire this is a reality
it's a reality so I hope that you got to
benefit continue to tune in every week
here to the Deen show or we have a new
show for you you can call us at